TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
SESSION OF THE SENATE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
I THINK IT APPROPRIATE --
AS WE CONVENE THAT WE BEGIN.
THIS SESSION --
WITH A MOMENT OF SILENCE FOR THE
VICTIMS.
OF THE WILL THE FIRE THE
CAMPFIRE.
AND I THINK IT IS WELL
APPROPRIATE PARTICULARLY AFTER
THE WEEKEND'S EVENTS AND TODAY'S
EVENTS THAT WE ALSO REFLECT ON
LIFE AND TIMES OF FORMER
PRESIDENT.
GEORGE H. W. BUSH SO IF WE COULD --
A BRIEF MOMENT OF SILENCE.
RESPECT AND REMEMBRANCE
.
WE'RE PLEASED --
YOU'LL HEAR THEM COMING FROM THE
BACK WILL BEGIN THIS MORNING
WITH MUSICAL PRELUDE A PERFORMED
BY SACRAMENTO'S OWNS.
CHILDREN'S CHORUS UNDER THE
DIRECTION OF ALEXANDER GRAHAM
BELL --
THEY'LL BEGIN WITH A NUMBER
SELECTIONS AND WILL MOVE ON
THANKS GUYS AND
TO THIS.
IS A THE WE SO [inaudible]
THAT'S
WELL [inaudible]
WELL
--
THANK YOU TO THE CHILDREN'S
COURT EVERYONE OF YOU.
FOR WHICH OF YOUR TIME --
IF YOU'RE WONDERING WHY I'M HERE --
I'LL REMIND YOU I AM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE SENATE. 88% AB
FOR GOD.
THIS IS A QUICKLY SEVEN YEARS
AND ELEVEN MONTHS TO GET
[inaudible]
THIS PODIUM.
AS YOUR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
I TELL THEM.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR ELECT DON'T
GET USED TO GET OUT OF THE
SENATE CHAMBERS.
I DON'T EXPECT MANY.
TIE BREAKING VOTES BUT IT'S AN
HONOR NONETHELESS AND I I JUST
WANT EXTEND THAT.
GRATITUDE METICULOUSLY TO MADAM
PRESIDENT PRO TEM --
TONI ATKINS --
WHO CAN CREDIBLY GRACE?
PERIOD SAID IN A PARTICULAR I
SEE IT NUMBER CHILDREN.
OUT THERE TO ALL THE CHILDREN --
WHOSE FAMILY MEMBER MAY HAVE.
MADE THEIR WAY TO THIS CHAMBERS
FOR THE SPECIAL DAY --
I AM EMPATHETIC TO YOU FIRST AND
FOREMOST AS A FATHER OF FOUR
BECAUSE I KNOW YOUR SACRIFICE.
BECAUSE OF YOUR LOVE ONE
SACRIFICE I KNOW IT'S TOUGH.
ON THE CHILDREN NOT SEEING THEIR
MOM OR DAD --
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
IMAGINE TODAY FILAMENT THERE
MORE ANXIETY.
AS OUR APPEARANCE EITHER.
THE MAGISTRATE IS CHAMBERS AND
ARE WORRIED THEY MAY SEE THEM
EVEN LESS --
BUT KNOW THAT --
THAT YOU'RE HERE IN THE SPIRIT.
THAT IN NIGHTS EACH AND EVERY
ONE OF US AND IN THAT SPIRIT IS
CONTRIBUTION.
THAT SPIRIT --
IS THE SPIRIT THAT DEFINES THIS
MOMENT.
ACTIVE.
NOT A NERD CITIZENSHIP.
WHILE WERE SWEARING AND FOLKS
WITH FORMAL AFFORDING.
I'D SUPPORT OUR MIND EACH AND
EVERYONE OF US THAT WE'RE NOT
JUST HERE EXERCISE IN OUR MORAL
RATHER FORMAL AUTHORITY WE NEED
TO EXERCISE.
THAT MORAL AUTHORITY IN THESE
CHAMBERS EACH AND EVERY DAY AS
WELL. TO THE SPOUSES. TO THE
HUSBAND HERE GETTING SWORN IN.
THE WIVES AS WELL EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE TO YOU FOR YOUR
SACRIFICE AND HARD WORK --
THIS IS A SPECIAL DAY FOR YOU AS
WELL AND TO ALL THE INCOMING.
MEMBERS --
THIS IS A DAY ON THEIR FORGET --
BUT LET US NOT FORGET WHY YOU'RE
HERE -- IN
THAT IS NOT TO BE SOMETHING TO
BUT TO DO SOMETHING.
I CAME OUT IN THIS CAMPAIGN
SHALL BE BRIEF IN MY WELCOMING
REMARKS MY REAL JOB IS.
TO ASK A CENTER LARA PURE.
BUT I HAD AN INTERESTING
OPPORTUNITY TO BE A CITIZENSHIP
CONFERENCE UP IN SEATTLE.
AND A GUY.
BY THE NAME ERIC LIU WAS TELLING
ME A STORY ABOUT A BILLBOARD IN
SEATTLE --
THAT WAS ON THERE A QUICKLY AND
OF THE FOUR OH FIVE FREEWAY ANY
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
APPRECIATE THIS.
AND AND THEY SAID THE BILLBOARD
A BIG BOLD LETTERS SAYS YOU'RE
NOT STUCK IN TRAFFIC.
IS THE MOST CONGESTED FREEWAY IN
[inaudible]
ENTIRE STATE.
ABOUT TWENTY MINUTES LATER YET
YOU SEE THAT BILLBOARDS YOU GET
ABOUT A HUNDRED YARDS CLOSER TO
IT.
YOU SEE IN PARENTHESES
UNDERNEATH THE BLAZING HEADLINE
THAT SAYS YOU'RE NOT STUCK IN
TRAFFIC.
IMPRENSA SEES IT SAYS YOU ARE
TRAFFIC [inaudible]
BY.
WHICH IS INTERESTING.
IT'S A REMINDER THAT SOCIETY
BECOMES HOW WE BEHAVE.
WE OUR OUR BEHAVIORS.
SO AT THE END OF THE DAY ARE JOB
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF US IS TO
RECONCILE THIS THAT WE HAVE
AGENCY.
THE ARE NOT BYSTANDERS IN THIS
WORLD THAT WE CAN SHAPE THE
FUTURE.
ITS DECISIONS.
THE DECISIONS YOU'LL MAKE HERE
IN THESE CHAMBERS.
DECISIONS YOU'LL MAKE ON BEHALF
OF THIRTY NINE PLUS MILLION
PEOPLE IN THE STATE THAT WILL
DETERMINE THE FATE AND FUTURE
NOT ONLY A PEOPLE IN THE STATE.
THE FOLKS AROUND THE REST OF
THIS COUNTRY AND HAVING JUST
GOTTEN BACK.
FROM MEXICO YESTERDAY AND MET
WITH MANY FOREIGN LEADERS PEOPLE
AROUND BECAUSE IT IS NOT A GROSS
EXAGGERATION THE WORLD IS
LOOKING TO US EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU.
NOT JUST TO LIVE TOGETHER AND
ADVANCE TOGETHER.
AND PROSPER TOGETHER.
BUT TO BE THAT INSPIRATION.
THAT SO MANY OF US AROUND THE
WORLD LOOKING TOO SO IT'S IN
THAT SPIRIT.
AND ALLIED I'M HERE SENSEOF
PRIDE.
AND GRATITUDE FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE --
AND FOR THE EXTRAORDINARY WORK
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU.
WILL BE DOING OVER THE COURSE OF
THE NEXT MONTHS AND YEARS OUR
MIND YOU IN CLOSING THE FUTURE
IS NOT SOMETHING TO EXPERIENCE.
IT'S SOMETHING TO MANIFEST.
NOT IN FRONT OF YOU IT'S INSIDE
OF YOU.
SO IT'S IN THAT.
THAT I WILL ASK CENTER LARA --
TO COME UP AND FORMALLY.
GAVEL THIS SESSION.
OF THE STATE SENATE AND AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS TO EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU ON THIS SPECIAL
DAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
THREATEN THE GOVERNOR BEFORE WE
OPENED THE SESSION LET --
ME HAVE A POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE. TO WELCOME OUR
CURRENT GOVERNOR THE ONE AND
ONLY GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN
.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE WANNA
KNOWLEDGE A COUPLE PEOPLE THAT
ARE HERE OUR SPECIAL GUEST. ONE
A BEGIN WITH OUR INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER DAVE JONES WAS HERE
LET'S GIVE HIM A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE.
OR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR ELECT
LENNY CALLIMACHUS IS HERE.
BOARD MEMBER OF ARE EQUALLY
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION BY A BOARD
MEMBER DIANE HARKEY IS HERE AS
WELL.
BOARD MEMBER ELECT TONY VASQUEZ
IS HERE.
THEN AS A SINGLES ONCE A SENATOR
ALWAYS A SENATOR GIVE --
HELP ME GIVE A ONE APPLIES TO
OUR FORMER MEMBERS SENATOR
RICHARD POLANCO WHO'S HERE.
SENATOR MARTHA IT'S SCHOOL DEAR.
SENATE IN FLORIDA THIS YEAR'S
WELL.
FORMER SENATOR SHE FOR IS ALSO
HERE.
CAN RUN ACROSS.
RETIRED AS A MEMBER LEVINE IS
HERE ALONG THE PRESENCE THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE.
OUR FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL
LOCKYER AND FORMER PRESIDENT OF
THIS HOUSE PRESIDENT PRO TEM.
MADAM PRO TEMPING YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE AS THE PRESIDING OFFICER
ONE LAST TIME. FOR THIS
WONDERFUL HOUSE MANY LIST OF ON
FOR NOW THE CALIFORNIA.
FAN TOLD HIM IN THE LOS FELIZ HE
THAT IS A LIST AND I WOULD HAVE
TO BE AN INTENT.
WHICH ARE WHICH IS WHAT THE
PHILLY SAID ALICE.
THE HOUR OF TWELVE TWENTY ONE
HAVING ARRIVED PURSUANT TO
ARTICLE FOUR SECTION THREE A OF
THE CONSTITUTION THE SENATE WILL
COME TO ORDER THE SENATORS WILL
PLEASE.
TAKE THEIR SEATS PURSUANT TO
SECTION NINE ONE FIVE ZERO OF
MARIE PARKER MINUTE KIRK ARE IN
THEIR RESPECTIVE PLACES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE RULES OF
THE HOUSE WILL BE SUSPENDED TO
ALLOW LOBBYIST ON THE FLOOR FOR
TODAY'S SESSION WITH THE MEMBERS.
AND MEMBERS SELECT AND OUR
GUESTS BE ON THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WILL BE LED IN THE PRAYER BY OUR
CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE
BOARDMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE.
THERE WILL BE THE PRESENTATION
OF THE COLORS BY THE SEA CAME
ACROSS THE HIGH SCHOOL JUNIOR
ROTC UNIT [inaudible]
SYSTEM SHOCK.
WELCOME TO THIS MOMENT OF PRAYER.
WE GATHER IN THE PRESENCE OF THE
HOLY.
ONE WHO HAS CALLED US TO BE CO
CREATORS OF OUR FUTURE.
AND THIS GOLDEN STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
GRACIOUS GOD OF MNY NAMES YOU
HAVE SAID IN ISAIAH.
FORTY THREE SEE I AM DOING A NEW
DATE.
EVEN NOW IT COMES TO LIGHTS.
CAN YOU NOT PERCEIVE IT.
I AM MAKING A WAY IN THE
WILDERNESS.
AND STREAMS IN THE WASTELAND.
HOLY AND MYSTERIOUS.
ONE AS WE BEGAN THIS SESSION OF
THE LEGISLATURE.
WE PAUSE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THIS MOMENT HAS BEEN IN PROCESS
FOR EONS.
THROUGH OUR ANCESTORS.
THEIR MOVEMENTS AND MIGRATIONS.
THIRD DREAMS AND LIFE CHANGING
DECISIONS.
TODAY WE THANK YOU FOR OUR NEW
SENATORS.
REELECTED SENATORS.
AND EXPERIENCED SENATORS.
ALL ENDEAVORING TO BRING NEW
HOPE AND NEW ENERGY TO THE WORK
OF LEADING OUR STATE.
WE ASK YOU NOW GRACIOUS GODS.
OPEN THEIR EYES TO SEE CLEARLY
AND COURAGEOUSLY.
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT LIE
BEFORE THEM.
INSPIRED THEIR IMAGINATIONS TO
CREATE SOME NEW SOLUTIONS TO
RECURRING AND EMERGING
SITUATIONS.
ENLIVEN THEIR HEARTS TO LOVE THE
WORK OF EACH DAY.
THOUSANDS AND THE DIFFICULT.
WE PRAY THAT EACH CONSTITUENTS
OF THE STATE.
WILL EMBRACE OUR CIVIC DUTY. TO
WORK FOR THE COMMON GOOD.
THAT TOGETHER WE ALL MAKE A
COMMITMENT. TO ACT A LITTLE MORE
JUSTLY. TO LIVE A LITTLE MORE
TENDERLY.
AND TO WALK A LITTLE MORE HUMBLY.
WITH YOU ARE GODS AND WITH EACH
OTHER [inaudible]
A MAN [inaudible]
COLOR GUARD.
POST THE COLORS
[inaudible] FOR
YOUR THE WELL.
WE WILL NOT BE LED IN THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
BY SENATOR ELECT SHINING GROW.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND HONORED
GUESTS PLEASE HELP ME SALUTE OUR
NATION'S FLAG.
I'VE DILIGENCE TO THE FLAG
[inaudible]
ALL [inaudible]
WORD [inaudible]
WELL IF.
THIS IS ABOUT [inaudible]
DON'T.
SAVE ALL WORK [inaudible] FIVE
MEMBERS AND GUESTS TO ME PLEASE
BE SEATED.
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME THE
SECRETARY THE SENATE WILL READ
THE THIRD CERTIFICATE OF
ELECTION OF THE DULY ELECTED
SENATORS.
SENATOR PLEASE READ.
BY ALEX PEDIA SECRETARY OF STATE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HEREBY CERTIFY THAT ACCORDING TO
THE SEMI OFFICIAL RESULTS
PROVIDED TO MY OFFICE BY COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS.
AS OF DECEMBER THIRD TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE PERSONS WHOSE NAMES
ARE HEREINAFTER SET FORTH APPEAR
TO HAVE RECEIVED THE PLURALITY
OF VOTES IN THEIR RESPECTIVE
STATE SENATE DISTRICTS.
AT THE NOVEMBER SIXTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN GENERAL ELECTION.
THAT OPPOSITE THEIR RESPECTIVE
GAMES ARE THE STATE SENATE
DISTRICTS FROM WHICH THEY HAVE
AS OF THIS DATE APPEAR TO HAVE
RECEIVED A PLURALITY OF THE
VOTES.
IN THE NAMES OF THE COUNTY OR
COUNTIES COMPRISING REFORMING A
PORTION OF THE DISTRICTS WITH
THE NAME OF ANY COUNTY ENTIRELY
WITHIN OR COMPRISING THE
DISTRICTS SHOWN IN CAPITAL
LETTERS.
MIKE REQUIRE SECOND DISTRICT.
JAMES NELSON FOURTH DISTRICT
RICHARD.
ANDREAS FORTUS EIGHTH DISTRICT
BOB I. CASKEY TENTH DISTRICT.
ANNA CABALLERO TWELFTH DISTRICT
MELISSA HURTADO FOURTEENTH
DISTRICT.
CHANNING GROW SIXTEENTH DISTRICT.
BOB HERTZBERG EIGHTEENTH
DISTRICT.
CONNIE LEIVA TWENTIETH DISTRICT.
SUSAN RUBIO TWENTY SECOND
DISTRICT.
MARIA ELENA DURAZO TWENTY FOURTH
BEEN OUT TWENTY SIX DISTRICT.
JEFF STONE TWENTY EIGHT DISTRICT
HOLLY J. MITCHELL THIRTY TH
DISTRICT.
BOB J. ARCHULETA THIRTY SECOND
TOM UMBERG. THIRTY FOURTH
DISTRICT.
PATRICIA C. BATES THIRTY SIX
BRIAN W. JONES THIRTY EIGHTH
DISTRICT AND BEN HUESO FORTY TH
DISTRICT.
IN WITNESS WHERE.
I HEARING TO SET MY HAND AND
AFFIXED THE GREAT SEAL OF STATE
CALIFORNIA THIS THURSDAY
DECEMBER.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OUT EXPEDIA
SECRETARY OF STATE.
THANK YOU THE NEXT ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS SENATE RESOLUTION
ONE BY SENATOR MONEY.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION.
SENATE RESOLUTION NE BY SENATOR
MONNING RELATIVE TO HOLD OVER
SENATORS.
THURMOND AND YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS ATTEND HONORED FOR
PRESENT SENATE RESOLUTION ONE
WHICH WILL HAVE THE HOLDOVERS
SENATORS TAKE THEIR SEATS AND
HAVE THE SENATORS ELECT PLEASE
PROCEED TO THE BAR OF THE SENATE.
TO TAKE THEIR OATH OF OFFICE
MEMBERS I REQUEST IN HIGH VOTE.
THE ROOM MEMBERS ARE MONIES
REQUESTING AN AYE VOTE ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR OF THE RESOLUTION STATE
BY. NINE ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY
NAY.
THE AIDS HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED GRADUATIONS.
THE SENATORS ELECT PLEASE
PROCEED TO THE BAR OF THE SENATE
TO TAKE YOUR OATH OF OFFICE
--
THE
THE PRESS ARE PRESIDENT PRO
TEM HAS SELECTED THE FOLLOWING
SENATORS. TO BE AN ESCORT
COMMITTEE FOR OUR CHIEF JUSTICE.
WHAT SENATORS LEYVA [inaudible]
JACKSON.
BATES AND CHIANG PROCEED TO THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER IN ORDER TO
ESCORT.
THE HONORABLE TENNEY CAN TELL
SUCKER WE'RE CHIEF JUSTICE OF
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT WHO
ADMINISTER THE OATH OF OFFICE
[inaudible]
SORRY [inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD MORNING PLEASE RAISE YOUR
RIGHT HAND TO BE SWORN.
I STATE YOUR NAME.
DO SOLEMNLY SWEAR OR AFFIRM.
THEN IT WILL SUPPORT AND DEFEND
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES.
AND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC.
FLORA THE MESSAGE THAT I WILL
BEAR TRUE FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE.
TO THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES.
AND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA THAT I TAKE THIS
OBLIGATION FREEWAY.
WITHOUT ANY MENTAL RESERVATION
ABOUT.
OR PURPOSE OF EVASION.
AND THEN I WILL WELL AND
FAITHFULLY DISCHARGE.
THIS TIME THE DUTIES UPON WHICH
I AM ABOUT TO ENTER.
AND MANY CAN GRADUALLY
[inaudible]
GREAT
.
IF FOR SENATORS CAN PLEASE TAKE
THEIR SEATS.
SO WE CAN CONTINUE WITH
[inaudible]
OUR CEREMONY
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
WILL BE BIG CAN CONTINUE WITH
THE CEREMONY.
THIS IS -- I
THINK ONE OF THE MOST SPECIAL
MOMENTS FOR OUR CENTERS ELECT
THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST TIME.
YOU'RE GONNA HEAR YOUR NAME
CALLED -- AS
WE TAKE THE OFFICIAL ROLE FOR
THE SENATE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
SO -- LET'S
BEGIN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OF ALL THE SENATORS
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
THEY'RE ALSO [inaudible]
GAINES [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WITH SO [inaudible]
HER TARA [inaudible]
JACKSON JONES [inaudible]
LARA [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROUGH [inaudible]
RUBIO INNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
BY KATHY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
MEMBERS OF SECRETARY NOT A
QUORUM IS PRESENT THE NEXT ORDER
OF BUSINESS IS SENATE RESOLUTION.
TWO BY SENATOR HERTZBERG MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION.
SENATE RESOLUTION TWO BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG RELATIVE TO THE
ELECTION OF OFFICERS. FOR
HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT IS
WITH GREAT PRIDE.
THE HUMILITY THAT I RISE.
TO PRESENT SENATE RESOLUTION TO
WHICH DESIGNATES THE OFFICERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. FOR
THE 200-019-2000 TWENTY SESSION.
FIRST TO ELECT.
THE EXTRAORDINARY TONY G. ATKINS
TO BE OUR PRO TEM.
SECOND.
ERICA CONTAINERS FROM THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY TO BE THE
SECRETARY OF THE SENATE.
AND JODY BARNETT THE THIRD. TO
BE DESIGNATED AS A SERGEANT ARMS
OF OUR SENATE CONSTITUTING THE
OFFICERS OF THE SENATE THE CITY
CALIFORNIA I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
MEMBER CENTER PARTS PROGRESS
QUEST AN AYE VOTE.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF THE
RESOLUTION SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTIONS
OF DR ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS THE OVER.
THE OATH OF OFFICE WILL NOW BE
ADMINISTERED TO THE NEWLY
ELECTED OFFICERS OF THE SENATE.
BY THE HONORABLE TONY CANCEL
PSYCHO YEAR CHIEF JUSTICE OF THE
SUPREME COURT OF CALIFORNIA WITH
THE OFFICERS PLEASE COME FORWARD.
I THANK YOUR NAME I TONY ATKINS
SOLEMNLY SWEAR YOU SOLEMNLY
SWEAR LEVELS AND FORMER DEFENSE
THAT I WILL SUPPORT AND DEFEND
THE CONSTITUTION.
AND THE CONSTITUTION AND IN THE
CONSTITUTION THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AGAINST ALL ENEMIES
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC AGAINST ALL
ENEMIES FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC.
WILL BEAR TRUE FAITH AND
ALLEGIANCE I WILL BEAR TRUE
FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE TO THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES TO THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT I
TAKE THIS OBLIGATION FREELY.
THAT I TAKE THIS OBLIGATION
FREELY WITHOUT ANY MENTAL
RESERVATION WITHOUT ANY MENTAL
RESERVATION OR PURPOSE OF YOU
GETTING FOR PURPOSE OF EVASION
AND THAT I WILL WELL AND
FAITHFULLY DISCHARGE I WILL WELL
AND FAITHFULLY DISCHARGE THE
DUTIES UPON WHICH I'M ABOUT TO
AND THE DUTIES UPON WHICH I'M
ABOUT. TO ENTER
.
PLEASE RAISE YOUR RIGHT HAND.
PINE STATE YOUR NAME BY FIVE
HUNDRED US DO SOLEMNLY SWEAR
SOLEMNLY SWEAR THAT I WILL
SUPPORT AND DEFEND BUT I WILL
SUPPORT AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES WITH THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AGAINST ALL
ENEMIES FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC THAT I WILL BEAR TRUE
FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE THAT I WILL
GO. TO THE GYM [inaudible]
THE TO THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION OF
THE UNITED STATES.
CONSTITUTION.
AND THE CONSTITUTION TUESDAY.
CALIFORNIA.
CAN I TAKE THIS OBLIGATION
FREELY WITHOUT ANY MENTAL
RESERVATION WITHOUT ANY MENTAL
RESERVATION OR PURPOSE.
TOWARDS THE DUTIES UPON WHICH
I'M ABOUT TO ENTER THE DUTIES
UPON WHICH I AM ABOUT TO ENTER
ISOLATION
.
ONLY IN CALIFORNIA CAN NOW.
FORMER IMMIGRANT GIRL FROM A
CLAIM ON OUR LEADER CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE WHEN AMAZING.
NOW IT IS MY PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE TO YOU.
ARE FORTY EIGHT PRESIDENT PRO
TEM OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
THE ONE AND ONLY THE AMAZING
HONORABLE TONY G. AFGHANS OF SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA
.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES.
AS IDEA JUST TOLD ARE A SERGEANT
AT ARMS NOW YOU TOO HAVE BEEN
UPSTAGED BY A CHILD.
IT HAPPENS TO ALL OF US AT ONE
POINT OR ANOTHER.
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU BOTH
CONGRATULATIONS TO EVERYONE I
WANT TO SAY WELCOME TO THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY SESSION
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
IT IS A PROFOUND HONOR TO
REPRESENT THE BIGGEST AND THE
GREATEST STATE IN AMERICA IN
ELECTIVE OFFICE.
AND TODAY WE GET TO PUT ASIDE
ELECTION YEAR DISPUTE AND
DIVISIONS AND COME TOGETHER AS
ONE CALIFORNIA.
IN THIS VERY SACRED SEAT OF
DEMOCRACY TO SERVE THE MOST
DIVERSE AND DYNAMIC CONSTITUENCY
IN THE WORLD.
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
SPOKEN. ONE CONTINUES TO SPEAK
VERY LOUDLY.
AS IS HER RIGHT.
AT THE CALIFORNIAN AN AMERICAN.
NEARLY TWO THIRDS OF REGISTERED
VOTERS CAST A BALLOT IN THIS
ELECTION A RECENT RECORD FOR NON
PRESIDENTIAL YEAR.
THEY SPOKE LOUDLY AND CLEARLY
THEY SENT US HERE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR VOICES ARE HEARD AT
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT.
AND TO WRITE THE NEXT TO NEW
BOLD CHAPTER OF THE STATE'S
HISTORY.
SPEAKING OF NEW AND BOLD.
I WANT TO CONGRATULATE SOMEONE
THAT I'VE BEEN PROUD TO CALL A
FRIEND IN A WORKING PARTNER.
SINCE HE WAS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR
AND I WAS A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
REMEMBER.
THOSE DAYS.
WE WILL MISS HIM AS PRESIDENT OF
THE SENATE BUT I SUSPECT WE'LL
BE HEARING A LOT MORE FROM HIM
OVER THE NEXT FOUR YEARS. TO MY
FRIEND IN OUR GOVERNOR ELECT
GAVIN NEWSOM. TO THE NUMBER OF
OUR OTHER CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS AND OFFICERS ELECT WHO
ARE HERE TODAY.
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE
PUT THEIR FAITH IN YOU.
AND I KNOW THAT YOU WERE UP HOLD
THEIR TRUST.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME MARK
INCOMING LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR AND
SENATE PRESIDENT.
DELANEY COULD NOT.
UNA LAKIS I'M GONNA GET IT RIGHT.
IT WAS A GREAT COMMERCIAL ANY.
AYE THE FIRST POSITION AND OUR
STATE'S HISTORY.
AND WHILE WE MAY NOT HAVE MANY
TIME BREAKING VOTES YOU ARE
ALWAYS WELCOME IN THIS CHAMBER.
AS OUR PRESIDENT.
OUR INCOMING INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER OUR DEAR FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE RICARDO LARA THE FIRST
OPENLY GAY PERSON ELECTED TO
STATEWIDE OFFICE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND YOU KNOW I'D.
GOVERNOR BROWN IT IS MORE THAN
AN HONOR TO HAVE YOU JOIN US
TODAY.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND YOUR PARTNERSHIP
THESE LAST EIGHT YEARS.
WE GOT IMPORTANT THINGS DONE IN
CALIFORNIA IS BETTER FOR IT
TODAY.
I WANNA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
VISION AND YOUR WISDOM
.
IT IS BEEN A REAL HONOR.
BUT I DO WANNA LET THE RECORD
REFLECT I DID OFFER HIM A NICER
CHAIR.
BUT AS WOULD BE TRUE OF OUR
GOVERNOR HE PICKS THE MORE
OBSCURE OUT OF THE WAY CHAIR
WHERE HE CAN WATCH.
AND AND JUST HAVE HIS OWN
THOUGHTS SO I DON'T WANT PEOPLE
TO THINK I GAVE YOU A LESSER
CHAIR MISTER GOVERNOR --
BUT WE WANT TO THANK YOU IT
TRULY HAS BEEN AN HONOR.
I ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE --
ANOTHER --
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICER WHO'S
WITH US TODAY WHO FOR NOW MAYBE
LEAVING PUBLIC OFFICE BUT I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE OUR INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER AS WELL.
DAVE JONES.
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
OUTSTANDING SERVICE TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
AT YOU KNOW IF I MAY I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE ANOTHER
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT.
RIGHT OVER THERE WERE SENATOR
WIENER NOW SETS.
IS THE DESK OF SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER ARE WAS THE DESK OF
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER GEORGE
MISS COUNTY.
FROM THAT DESK HE PASSED
LANDMARK BILLS ESTABLISHING THE
SCHOOL LUNCH PROGRAM PROMOTING
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF WOMEN
AND LGBT CALIFORNIANS. FORTY
YEARS AGO LAST WEEK GEORGE
MOSCONI WAS SLAIN IN THE PRIME
OF HIS PUBLIC SERVICE CAREER.
ALONG WITH HIM SUPERVISOR HARSH
IN HARVEY MILK WAS STOLEN FROM
US BY THAT VERY SAME TRAGEDY.
AND I THEIR SAY WITHOUT THEIR
LEGACIES AND THEIR LEADERSHIP I
WOULDN'T BE HERE TODAY A PROUD
MEMBER OF THE LGBT COMMUNITY.
LEADING THE MST EFFECTIVE
LEGISLATIVE BODY IN AMERICA.
AND TOGETHER AS WE WORK TO MAKE
HISTORY WE MUST ALWAYS REMEMBER
OUR OWN HISTORY.
YOU KNOW WE'RE FORTUNATE TO FIND
OURSELVES IN THIS PARTICULAR
MOMENT IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
IN THE CALIFORNIA STORY. TEN
YEARS AFTER FINANCIAL CRISIS
THROUGH OUR STATE INTO DISARRAY
WERE BACK ON OUR FEET.
WE'VE COME FROM UNGOVERNABLE
MESS TO UNDENIABLE SUCCESS.
WE FOUGHT HARD TO GET WHERE WE
ARE TODAY.
CLIMBING OUT OF THE WORST
RECESSION SINCE THE GREAT
DEPRESSION.
SLOWLY RESTORING THE VITAL FUNDS
THAT WE WERE FORCED TO CUT FROM
OUR CLASSROOMS FROM OUR CLINICS.
AND FROM OUR COMMUNITY CENTERS.
TODAY WE'RE REACHING NEW HEIGHTS
IN JOB GROWTH AND EMPLOYMENT
LEVELS IN NEW AND NEW LOWS IN
THE RATES OF THE UNINSURED.
WE ARE INVESTING MORE IN K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION THAN
EVER BEFORE.
WE'VE HAD INCREASED OUR
INVESTMENT IN UC AND CSU TWO OF
OUR STATES MOST IMPORTANT PUBLIC
RESOURCES.
AND THANKS TO THE LEGISLATURE
THE UC HAS INCREASED ITS
COMMITMENT TO SERVING CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
WE'RE REBUILDING VITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT KEEPS OUR
ECONOMY MOVING AND GROWING OUR
ROADS ARE TRANSIT AND HOUSING.
WE'RE TAKING AGGRESSIVE STEPS TO
LIVE FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY AND
HELPING WORKING CLASS HOUSEHOLDS
MEET THEIR NEEDS.
AND WE'VE TORN DOWN THE WALL OF
DEBT.
WHILE BUILDING RECORD RESERVES
TO NEARLY SIXTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS.
WE ALL KNOW THE GOVERNOR BROWN
DESERVES ENORMOUS CREDIT FOR
LEADING US THROUGH TURBULENT
TIMES.
LET ME BE CLEAR THIS BODY ALONG
WITH THE ASSEMBLY DOWN THE HALL
HAS BEEN AT LEAST EQUAL PARTNERS
ALONG THE WAY.
IT'S BEEN A GREAT PARTNERSHIP.
WE'VE LEARNED FROM OUR PAST
MISTAKES.
AND JUST AS MANY OF US ARE THAT
SERVED.
UNDER GOVERNOR BROWN ARE STILL
WHO ARE TO SERVE WITH GOVERNOR
ELECT GAVIN NEWSOM THEIR
SENATORS THAT WERE SWORN IN
TODAY WHO WILL SERVE WITH THE
NEXT GOVERNOR.
GOVERNOR'S MAY RECEIVE THE
LION'S SHARE OF THE CREDIT.
OR THE BLAME.
BUT LAWMAKERS SHARE THE ULTIMATE
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND IT SENATORS WE EACH HAVE A
VOTE AND WITH IT A VERY PERSONAL
STAKE IN PROTECTING OUR STATE'S
FINANCES.
AND OUR FUTURE.
WE MAY BE PREPARED TO AND DURING
THE FIGURATIVE RAINY DAYS.
BUT WE HAVE MUCH WORK TO DO TO
PROTECT OUR STATE.
AND OUR COMMUNITIES FROM THE
VERY REAL RAVAGES OF NATURE.
ALREADY THIS DECADE WE'VE
ENTERED FIVE YEARS OF HISTORIC
DROUGHT.
SINCE OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR WE'VE
BEEN GEORGE SIX OF THE TEN MOST
DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES IN OUR
HISTORY INCLUDING THE CAMPFIRE
THE MOST LETHAL.
AND WE NO THE RISK OF THOSE
FIRES DON'T END WITH THE LAST
EMBERS HAVE BEEN PUT OUT.
AS WE SAW WITH THE DEVASTATING
MUD SLIDES IN VENTURA COUNTY.
BUT NOW BYE NOW EVERYONE OF OUR
FORTY SENATE DISTRICTS HAS FELT
THE CONSEQUENCES.
OF A WARMING CLIENT.
IN ONE WAY OR ANOTHER WE HAVE
FELT IT.
AND I WANT TO TAKE A MINUTE TO A
KNOWLEDGE MEMBERS OF OUR HARDEST
HIT COMMUNITIES. FOR THEIR
TIRELESS ADVOCACY AND WHOLE
HEARTED COMMITMENT TO RECOVERY.
SENATORS MCGUIRE STERN DODD
NIELSEN GAINES AND JACKSON TO
NAME ONLY A FEW.
I FELT THE IMPACTS CLOSE TO HOME.
VERY CLOSE TO HOME.
SO CLOSE IN FACT THAT SENATOR
STERN LOST HIS HOME.
IN THE WALLS THE FIRE.
AND YET WITHOUT REGARD FOR THEIR
OWN LOSSES ALL OF THEM.
OR NEAR LOSSES THEY'VE BEEN
RELENTLESS REPRESENTATIVES FOR
THEIR NEIGHBORS FIRST.
I WANT ACKNOWLEDGE ANOTHER
COLLEAGUE DR JIM WOOD R. SIMPLY
COLLEAGUE DOWN THE HALL.
WHOSE OWN COMMUNITY WAS
DEVASTATED --
BY FIRE A YEAR AGO.
AS A LAWMAKER DOCTOR WHAT IS
TAKEN A LEADING ROLE IN OUR
POLICY RESPONSES AS YOU KNOW TO
WILDFIRES ALONG WITH A NUMBER OF
OUR COLLEAGUES.
BUT AS A FORENSIC DENTIST HE'S
ALSO QUIETLY TAKEN ON THE HEART
WRENCHING BURDEN OF IDENTIFYING
VICTIMS.
ON BEHALF OF THIS CHAMBER I WANT
TO OFFER MY DEEPEST GRATITUDE TO
DR WOULD. TO ARE INCREDIBLE
SENATORS HERE TODAY. TO THE
THOUSANDS OF FIRST RESPONDERS ON
THE FRONT LINES.
AND ALSO TO ALL OF THE GOOD
SAMARITANS ACROSS OUR STATE WHO
ARE RISING TO THE OCCASION. TO
HEAL HOWLS AND SUPPORT SURVIVORS.
THEIR HUMBLE ACTS OF HUMANITY
SHOULD MAKE US ALL PROUD.
WE CAN HONOR THE VICTIMS AND
THEIR SACRIFICES AND SO MANY OF
THE SACRIFICES OF OUR NEIGHBORS
BY TAKING PRO ACTIVE STEPS TO
PREPARE.
FOR AND WHERE POSSIBLE PREVENT
THE NEXT TRAGEDY BEFORE IT
REACHES ARE VERY COMMUNITIES.
WE CAN AFFORD TO IGNORE THE
EXTRAORDINARY FINANCIAL COST
EITHER OF THOSE DISASTERS WHICH
ARE MOUNTING HERE AND ACROSS THE
NATION.
ACCORDING TO FEDERAL STATISTICS
NOT GO GIVE YOU A LOT OF
STATISTICS.
CLIMATE AND WEATHER DISASTERS
COST AMERICANS MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS ALONE
LAST YEAR THAT'S NOT JUST IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S ACROSS OUR
COUNTRY.
AND WE MAY NEVER BE ABLE TO
FULLY MEASURE THE ECONOMIC AND
THE HEALTH BURDENS OF THE THICK
CLOUDS OF SMOKE HANGING OVER OUR
COMMUNITIES EVEN TODAY.
CLOUDS OF FORCE MORE THAN ONE
MILLION CHILDREN FROM THEIR
CLASSROOMS.
LEAVING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF OUR
NEIGHBORS HOMELESS AND CALLSAND
COUNTLESS LOST WORKDAYS THAT
AFFECT INDIVIDUALS ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES AND ARE VERY ECONOMY.
WE'RE IN UNCHARTED TERRITORY.
AND ALL SIGNS INDICATE WE'VE
ONLY JUST BEGUN TO FEEL THE
HARSH NEW REALITIES OF A WARMING
PLANET.
WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
IMPACTS REACH ACROSS EVERY FACET
OF OUR LIVES FROM PUBLIC HEALTH
TO HOUSING EDUCATION AND OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
RESILIENT.
AND NOW WE NEED TO INSURE THAT
ARE BUILT ENVIRONMENTS ARE AS
WELL.
THAT'S OUR NEXT CHALLENGE.
WE TOOK IMPORTANT STEPS THIS
YEAR TO ADAPT INCLUDING
REVAMPING OUR EMERGENCY RESPONSE
PROTOCOLS.
AND WE BECAME THE FIRST MAJOR
ECONOMY ON EARTH TO COMMIT TO A
100% CLEAN ENERGY BY.
TWENTY FORTY FIVE BUT WE HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO IN A SHORT AMOUNT
OF TIME IF WE WANT TO AVOID EVEN
WORSE DAYS.
AHEAD FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
SO WE HAVE QUITE A BIT OF WORK
STILL TO DO. TO GET OUR OWN
HOUSE IN ORDER AS WELL.
WE HAVE BIG CHALLENGES BIG
ISSUES.
WE ALSO HAVE INTERNAL ISSUES
THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON I SAID WHEN I TOOK THIS
OFFICE THAT MY MANDATE WOULD BE
TO RAISE THE STANDARDS OF
CONDUCT.
AND PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY IN
THE SENATE AN IN THIS CAPITAL.
I MEANT IT THEN AND I MEAN IT
NOW.
WE'VE TAKEN STEPS THROUGH OUR
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE TO
IMPLEMENT CONFIDENTIAL REPORTING.
SYSTEM AND AN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS TO BOTH
PROTECT VICTIMS.
OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT AND ENSURE
JUSTICE IS SERVED.
BUT WE CAN'T BE SATISFIED WITH
OUR PROGRESS BECAUSE THESE STEPS
ALONE WON'T CHANGE THE CULTURE.
OF THIS BUILDING.
ONLY WE CAN DO THAT.
AND THE HARD TRUTH IS THAT THIS
WORK WILL NEVER BE FINISHED
BECAUSE THERE IS NO FINAL
DESTINATION.
CALIFORNIA.
IN SO MANY WAYS WE ARE A STUDY
IN PROGRESS BUT WE'RE ALSO A
WORK IN PROGRESS WE CAN'T AFFORD
COMPLACENCY WE STILL HAVE SO
MUCH WORK TO DO.
BECAUSE THE GULF BETWEEN HAVES
AND HAVE NOTS IN THE STATE IS AS
WIDE AS OUR LEGENDARY CENTRAL
VALLEY IS VAST.
AND IT'S ONLY GROWING.
HOUSING PRICES HAVE SOARED OUT
OF REACH FOR WORKING FAMILIES
AND DESPITE OUR RECENT EFFORTS
WERE NOT BUILDING NEARLY ENOUGH
TO MEET THAT DEMAND.
IN A STATE KNOWN FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION OVER A
MILLION RESIDENTS STILL DON'T
HAVE RELIABLE CLEAN DRINKING
WATER.
AND MILLIONS MORE BRIEF THE MOST
POLLUTED AIR IN OUR NATION.
THESE CONTRAST THE FINE ARTS
CHALLENGE.
AS LAWMAKERS WE MUST HELP TO
HARNESS CALIFORNIA'S EXTRA
ORDINARY BOUNTIES IN ORDER TO
MEET OUR MANY URGENT NEEDS.
WE MUST ALIGN OUR ACTIONS WITH
OUR VALUES.
IF WE DON'T ACKNOWLEDGE THESE
CHALLENGES WE WILL NEVER
OVERCOME THEM.
SO I CHALLENGE EACH OF YOU TO
SEARCH WITHIN YOURSELVES.
THIS SESSION TO FIND THE URGENCY
WE WILL NEED TO MATCH THE TASK
BEFORE US.
WE CAN DO MORE TO BRIDGER
DIVIDES TO LIFT UP THOSE WERE
FALLING BEHIND WE CAN REWARD
AMBITION.
AND INGENUITY AND LEARN FROM OUR
FAILURES.
WHATEVER THE CASE WE MUST
CONTINUE TO TAKE RISK AND TO
MAKE PROGRESS.
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH WE'RE DOING
WELL WE AREN'T DOING ENOUGH.
AFTER ALL WE'RE THE STATE OF
INVENTION NOT CONVENTION.
AND THAT'S WHAT DEFINES
CALIFORNIA.
SOUND FAMILIAR AND AS I THOUGHT
YOU WOULD.
THROUGH PIONEERING SPIRIT THAT
PENSION FOR IMAGINATION IS WHAT
MADE CALIFORNIA THE ENVY OF THE
WORLD AND THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY ON EARTH.
WHETHER IT WAS THE VISION OF SO
MANY IMMIGRANTS FROM AROUND THE
WORLD TO COME TO OUR VALLEYS AND
GROW THE GREATEST HARVEST THE
WORLD HAS EVER SEEN.
OR THE INITIATIVE OF INDUSTRY
OUTCAST THE BILL THE IN
ENTERTAINMENT CAPITAL OF THE
WORLD IN A DUSTY LITTLE TOWN.
CALLED HOLLYWOOD.
AT THE CAPTURE SO MANY HEARTS
AND MINDS AND IMAGINATIONS ON
EVERY CONTINENT.
OR THE INGENUITY OF A SON OF A
SYRIAN IMMIGRANTS TO START APPLE
COMPUTER IN A GARAGE IN LOS
ALTOS AND CHANGE THE WAY.
THE WORLD WORKS.
THAT COULD INFLUENCE OF OPEN
MINDS CREATIVITY AND DARING WHAT
EVER YOU WANT TO CALL IT.
THAT IS CALIFORNIA'S GREATEST
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE.
THERE IS NO PLACE ON EARTH MORE
CAPABLE OF MAKING DREAMS REALITY.
AND NO GROUP OF CALLING.
NO GROUP OF COLLEAGUES MORE
CAPABLE OF MAKING HISTORY.
AND NOW IT IS MY INCREDIBLE
HONOR TO RECOGNIZE OUR
REPUBLICAN LEADER.
A WOMAN THAT IS MY PARTNER IN
THE SENATE AND LEADING THIS
COLLECTIVE BODY SENATOR PAT
BATES SENATOR BATES
.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WHAT A WHAT AN INCREDIBLE DAY
YOU GUYS SO I AM GOING TO GET
OFF MY PREPARED SPEECH FOR JUST
A MINUTE?
AND SAY TO OUR OUR GOVERNOR AND
MARRIAGE IS NOT QUITE THANK YOU
GOVERNOR BROWN FOR AN INCREDIBLE --
HISTORY OF THAT SHE LEFT THE
STATE A LEGACY OF PUBLIC SERVICE
THAT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AYE MY
GRAND KIDS HERE.
A HOPEFUL INSPIRING AND NOT HAVE
THEM FOLLOW OUR THAT'S WHAT'S
MADE IT A GREAT A GREAT STATE
AGREED COLLECTIVE FAMILY IF YOU
WILL.
ARE CERTAINLY TO OUR INCOMING --
GOVERNOR FOR A FEW MORE HOURS.
WE WISH YOU THE VERY BEST AND
WE'RE HERE TO WORK ALONGSIDE OF
YOU AGAIN.
TO FIVE ADVANCE ADVANCES
WONDERFUL --
FAMILY THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WALKING
THAT WALK IT WAS TOUGH LIKE FOR
ALL OF US WE KNOW WHAT THAT'S
LIKE.
ANYWAY --
WE'RE GLAD TO HAVE YOU WITH US
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO RETURNING --
IN JANUARY TO WORK SIDE BY SIDE.
INTO MY I HAVE TO SAY MY
FAVORITE PRO TEM.
OUR WHAT SHE SAID TODAY I
BELIEVE AND HER INSPIRING
REMARKS INVITE LOOK AROUND THIS
ROOM WHAT WHAT IS IT FIELD
WEALTHIEST FILLED WITH FAMILY A
CEMENT IS FILLED WITH FRANCE.
IS FILLED WITH PEOPLE FROM ALL
OVER CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE HERE
BINDING TOGETHER.
OUGHT TO COME YET TO MAKING OUR
CALIFORNIA EVEN BETTER THAN
IDEAS GREATER THAN IDEAS IN IT
ONLY GETS THAT WAY BECAUSE WE
WORK TOGETHER.
AS A FAMILY AND YOU SET THAT
TONE --
SENATOR ATKINS WHERE ARE YOU
THAT.
ON BEHALF OF MY CAUCUS MEMBERS
ARE THEY SHARE THOSE VERY
THOUGHTS WE'VE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS SINCE THE ELECTION
AND WE ARE HERE TO DO THE JOB.
AND THEY HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU A WIN
OR LOSE SAW WE'RE HERE TO WORK
TOGETHER.
AND I KNOW THEY SHARE MY REMARKS --
IN TERMS OF OUR A RETIRING
GOVERNOR AND OUR NEW GOVERNOR
COMING IN.
BY WE MAY COME FROM DIFFERENT
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA AND
DIFFERENT POLITICAL PARTIES WHAT
WE AGREE ON ONE THING.
THE NEED TO ENSURE THAT THIS
HOUSE THIS HOUSE REPRESENTS ALL
CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE THEY ARE
OUR COLLECTIVE FAMILY.
EACH SENATOR REPRESENTS THE
HOPES DREAMS AND INTERESTS OF
ALMOST A MILLION DIVERSE PEOPLE
IN OUR FAMILY.
BEING A SENATOR IS TRULY AN
HONOR AND A TREMENDOUS
RESPONSIBILITY.
ON BEHALF OF MY CAUCUS AGAIN I
WANT TO CONGRATULATE ALL THE
MEMBERS FROM BOTH PARTIES WHO
TOOK THEIR OATH OF OFFICE TODAY.
WE KNOW THAT IT WAS A DIFFICULT
PATH FOR EACH AND EVERYONE OF US
AND WE ARRIVED HERE I LIKE TO
SAYTHAT I SERVED THE BLUE WAVE
AND I LANDED ON ON THE SURE.
YOU KNOW I'M HERE TO CONTINUE MY
WORK OUR OLD NOT AS DEMOCRATS
REPUBLICANS THAT IS
REPRESENTATIVES OF ALL THE
PEOPLE OF OUR GREAT STATE.
I SPECIALLY CONGRATULATE THE NEW
MEMBERS WHO WILL BE TAKING WHO
TOOK THEIR OATH OF OFFICE FOR
THE VERY FIRST TIME WE KNOW YOU
WORKED VERY HARD TO BE HERE
TODAY.
THIS IS YOUR MOMENT AND THIS IS
THE MOMENT FOR YOUR FAMILIES WHO
WALKED THAT WALK WITH YOU.
ARE YOU ARE JOINING THE MOST
INFLUENTIAL STATE SENATE IN THE
NATION ONE THAT HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF CUSTOMS AND PRACTICES
THAT EMPHASIZE COLLEGIALITY.
TOGETHER WE BELIEVE IN HAVING AN
INSTITUTION WHERE WE HAVE STRONG
PROCESS SEES IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THAT EACH SENATOR IN EACH STAFF
MEMBER CAN DO THE PEOPLE'S WORK.
IN A SAFE AND RESPECTFUL
ENVIRONMENT AND I WILL SAY THE
PROTIUM SET THAT TONE OF LAST
YEAR WHEN WE HAD OUR DIFFICULT
MOMENTS.
TOGETHER WE HAVE WORK TOGETHER
TO IMPROVE THE CULTURE THAT
CHARACTERIZES THE SENATE.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO BUILDING
ON THAT PROGRESS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
LEGISLATION AND OVERSIGHT ARE
BOTH CRITICALLY IMPORTANT RULES
OF THE SENATE PERFORMS BOTH THE
PRO TIM AND I ARE COMMITTED TO
ENSURING THAT THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO PERFORM.
THESE RULES WELL IN THE NEW
SESSION BECAUSE ULTIMATELY THE
HOUSE BELONGS TO THE PEOPLE WE
SERVE OUR FAMILY. TO ALL MY
COLLEAGUES CONGRADULATIONS BEST
WISHES I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU WHEN WE RETURN HERE.
JANUARY SEVENTH TO BEGIN OUR
WORK TOGETHER IN EARNEST THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR THE HONOR
TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES AND PUT
HIM ATKINS OF FOR YOUR COMMENTS --
JUST WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY THOUGH TO RECOGNIZE
RETIRE PRO TEM AND SENATOR JOHN
BURTON.
AROUND OF A PLUS
.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS WERE --
NOW GOING TO MOVE ON THERE ARE
MESSAGES AT THE DESK FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS.
OKAY THE NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS --
IS SENATE RESOLUTION.
THREE BY.
SENATOR SENATOR ATKINS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS REST VERY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION THREE BY
SENATOR ATKINS RELATIVE TO THE
ELECTION OF MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES.
THANK YOU.
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS SR
THREE WOULD ELECT SENATORS WILK
GROVE MINING AND ROTH AS MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES
FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
REGULAR SESSION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
CITY RECKONS REQUESTS AND I VOTE
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF THE
RESOLUTION SAY ALL BY.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE
THE AYE AYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
THE NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
SENATE RESOLUTION FOUR BY
SENATOR ATKINS.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION.
SENATE RESOLUTION FOUR BY
SENATOR ATKINS RELATIVE TO THE
STANDING RULES OF THE SENATE FOR
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
REGULAR SESSION.
INTERACTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SR FOR
CONTAINS A STANDING RULES OF THE
SENATE THE RULES CONTAINED IN US
OUR FOR ARE SIMILAR. TO THE
SENATE RULES FOR THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN REGULAR
SESSION THERE'VE BEEN TECHNICAL
CHANGES MADE AS WELL AS A
REWRITE.
OF SENATE RULE TWELVE POINT
THREE WHICH PERTAINS TO THE ROLE
OF THE SENATE ON BUD'S PERSON.
THE CHANGING ROLE TWELVE POINT
THREE SEPARATES THE IONS PER ARM
BUDS PERSON ROLE FROM THE ETHICS
COUNCIL WHICH INCORPORATES THE
BEST PRACTICES DEVELOPED.
WITH OUR LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ON THIS MEASURE.
ROUTE THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS --
CENTER ACTIONS REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF THE
RESOLUTION SAY AYE.
AYE.
THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
THE NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
BY SENATOR WILK.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
BY SENATOR WILK RELATIVE TO THE
ADOPTION OF THE JOINT RULES OF
THE SENATE AN ASSEMBLY FOR THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY REGULAR
SESSION.
THIRD WILL COMMIT PROCEED THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS
ESSIE R. ONE CONTINUES THE JOINT
RULES FOR THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY.
THESE RULES ARE IN ESSENCE THE
SAME AS THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN CHOI RULES
THE CHANGES ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE FOR EXAMPLE JOINT RULE
THE CURRENT LEGISLATIVE CALENDAR.
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
GREAT THANK YOU SENATOR WILK.
THE RESOLUTION REQUIRES TWENTY
ONE VOTES TO BE ADOPTED.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
I BILL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
BY BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
HI DORADO [inaudible]
I GAINES BYE BYE GALGIANI
[inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
BY HUESO.
BY HER TITLE [inaudible]
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
BY LARA.
AYE LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING [inaudible]
BY MORLOCK [inaudible]
BY RAIL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH.
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
BY.
A BURKE I BY BY KATHY.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK.
BY.
I IS THIRTY NINE THOSE ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
THE NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO
BY SENATOR ROTH.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO
BY SENATOR ROTH RELATIVE TO THE
SELECTION OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL OF CALIFORNIA.
SENATOR ROBB.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SCR TO WHICH SELECTED
DIANNE BOYER VINE AS THE
LEGISLATURE'S.
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL FOR THE
200-019-2000 TWENTY SESSION.
AS YOU KNOW MS BOYER VINE JOIN
THE OFFICE OF LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
AND WAS APPOINTED THE
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL IN. TWO
THOUSAND TWO FOR SIXTEEN YEARS
SHE IS SERVED OF THE LEGISLATURE
WELL AS OUR LEGAL COUNSEL.
AND AS IN A PRESS A PRACTICING
ATTORNEY FOR FORTY FOUR YEARS
THIS MONTH I THINK I KNOW A GOOD
WHEN WHEN I SEE.
ONE AND SHE IS A GREAT ATTORNEY
I AM THROUGH Z. AS TO CLEAR CHEN
AYE VOTE ON S. C. R..
TO THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH --
MEMBERS THE RESOLUTION REQUIRES
TWENTY ONE VOTES TO BE ADOPTED
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I BILL.
HI WERE JUST.
BY BRADFORD.
BY CABALLERO.
I CHIANG.
AYE DODD [inaudible]
HI DORADO.
I GAINES AYE AYE GALGIANI
[inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
BY WITH SO.
HI HER TITLE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES.
BY LARA.
AYE LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
HI MERRELL.
I NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH.
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
HI SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE.
BUY A BURKE.
BY.
I COUNTY.
BY WINNER.
HI WILK.
BY.
ICE FORTY KNOWS ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED --
THE NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
SENATE ROUTE RESOLUTION NUMBER
FIVE BY SENATOR SKINNER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION SENATE RESOLUTION
FIVE BY SENATOR SKINNER.
RELATIVE TO NOTIFYING THE
GOVERNOR OF THE ORGANIZATION OF
THE SENATE [inaudible]
SENATOR SKINNER.
MISTER PRESIDENT MISS PRESIDENT
PRO TEMPORE MEMBERS SR FIVE
WOULD HAVE THE PRESIDENT PRO
TEMPORE OF THE SENATE.
APPOINT A SPECIAL COMMITTEE TO
WAIT UPON HIS EXCELLENCY THE
GOVERNOR AND INFORM HIM THAT THE
SENATE IS DULY ORGANIZED FOR THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
REGULAR SESSION.
AND IS NOW READY TO RECEIVE ANY
COMMUNICATION HE MAY HAVE TO
MAKE TO THIS HOUSE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
SENATOR SKINNER REQUESTS AND I
VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF THE
RESOLUTION SAY HI.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
THE PRESIDENT PRO TEM HAS
APPOINTED SENATOR SKINNER.
BRADFORD STERN DORADO AND JONES
TO CALL UPON THE GOVERNOR.
THE NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
SENATE RESOLUTION SIX BY CENTER
HUESO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION SENATE RESOLUTION SIX
BY SENATOR HUESO.
RELATIVE TO NOTIFYING THE
ASSEMBLY OF THE ORGANIZATION OF
THE SENATE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS S. R. SIX WOULD HAVE THE
PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE A OF THE
SENATE.
APPOINT A SPECIAL COMMITTEE TO
NOTIFY THAT THE SENATE IS DULY
ORGANIZED FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY REGULAR
SESSION AND IS READY TO PROCEED
WITH THE BUSINESS OF THE STATE.
HIGHER GINGIVAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER WAY
SO -- CENTER%
HUESO REQUESTS AN AYE VOTE ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR RESOLUTION.
SAY I ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
DICE HAVE AT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED THE PRESIDENT PRO TEM
HAS APPOINTED SENATORS GALGIANI.
DODD AND CAPITAL EURO --
TO CALL ON THE ASSEMBLY.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER BUSINESS TO
COME BEFORE THE HOUSE
[inaudible]
SENATOR ACTIONS.
THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT A
REMINDER TO THE NEWLY FORMED
RULES COMMITTEE THAT WE WILL
MEET FOR A FEW MINUTES IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE AT THE
CONCLUSION.
OF SESSION AND WITH THAT I
BELIEVE ARE PRESIDING OFFICER --
WILL CLOSE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING EVERYONE AFTER A
WONDERFUL HOLIDAY BACK HERE ON
JANUARY SEVENTH THANK YOU MISTER
RIGHT THANK YOU.
CENTER PRO TEM.
THE DESK WILL REMAIN OPEN UNTIL
THE HOUR OF THREE THIRTY BEFORE
THE INTERSECTION OF BILLS.
THE SENATE WILL STAND IN RECESS
UNTIL MONDAY JANUARY SEVENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN AT TWO PM.
THE SENATE IS NOW IN RECESS